Paul whether one is a new filmmaker or
more seasoned what would you advise in
terms of the best practices for
submitting to film festivals what are
some of your sort of quick and dirty
little cheat sheet cliff notes that you
would give someone well they're
different for seasoned filmmakers versus
new filmmakers if you've been on the
circuit before it's far easier to
navigate the circuit I think with with
our first film that we did it on the
circuit 10:00 till noon we spent like
$3,000 in submission fees flash-forward
to favor which is the third villain in
the circuit I think we spent like $300
in submission fee it's like you just
once you when you're an unknown
commodity you go out you have to pay
full fees and to everybody but when
you've been around the circuit before
and you played in other festivals you
can always write to them ask for waivers
they don't always give them to you but
often they do or at least a discount and
the Austin Film Festival once you've
played there you get a $25 $25 to submit
again late early whatever it's a flat
fee that's a huge savings there late
fees like a hundred bucks something like
that with favor
Blaine Weaver my actor had been in the
Austin Film Festival for so I was able
to to get that that alumni fee so you
can you can save a lot of money that way
so that's different when you played it
before you have an advantage you're
known you can get around the entries but
even if you're a first-time filmmaker a
couple things you should do one submit
early submitting late is always more
expensive and your odds of getting it
are far lower they start programming a
lot of ways so you want to get in the
door you if you submit early and they
like your film they're gonna mentally
put you on the schedule if you submit
late and they like your film they have
to like your film better than something
else they've already mentally put on the
schedule so you go in early you're not
being graded on a curve you go in late
you are just the way it is but also the
submission fee differences between early
and late are astounding like I think
early average few early like 50 bucks
average for you late fees a hundred
bucks I mean that's crazy so submit
early and then be wise about where you
submit you know I just I think that if
you have a $5,000 feature with no stars
and you have no connections
it's film festival don't submit to the
Sundance Film Festival that makes no
sense and don't be like well you never
know
no you know you do know you're not
getting in especially if you submit late
because their programs setting in
mid-july you know all this out most of
the submissions come in in a September
when everybody's rushing to get it you
know under the under the wire you have
no chance the schedule is set
you're literally 125 dollars to pay for
Laurence Fishburne's hotel room that's
literally what you're doing I know the
goodness of your heart and you're
sending them a coaster of your movie to
for their cold drinks that's basically
about it and you know this would be why
isn't you know do your homework a good
thing to do is if you're thinking of
something to a festival and I know
there's a lot of legwork but what you do
is go to the website of that festival
and look at the previous year's program
if they're playing nothing but Cuban
American films as the Miami Film
Festival does and your film takes place
in Saskatchewan don't submit there maybe
it's not that maybe you should submit to
the Fort Lauderdale Film Fest which is a
wider program you know some programs
have certain specific directors or taste
if you've made a mumblecore film don't
submit to Fantastic Fest you know it's
be wise
you're a good batting average or getting
into festivals is about 25% that's
pretty strong so for a first filmmaker
so if you want to get a 10 film
festivals you had to submit to 40 submit
early don't be afraid to write for
waivers if you know somebody or know
somebody who knows somebody you never
know so let's go back to that first-time
filmmaker because it sounds like a lot
of research so should really be put in
did you make like a spreadsheet document
did you were you that organized where
you tracked I wish we were there
organized we we blundered into it that
was the whole point behind making
official rejection was that hopefully
filmmakers are coming a little bit wiser
we kind of blundered we got a block like
we'll start with Sundance late and then
we'll Bob scattershot
and now a little more organized about it
I might think a good rule of thumb is
don't rush to finish your film finish it
what needs to be finished you know don't
don't don't send an unfinished movie
because you just know they'll check
they'll see
spirit of it no it's gonna be good when
the cuts done and the mixes they're
looking for any reason to reject your
movie think about when you were casting
your film
and you got stacks and stacks of
headshots you like to give one part you
maybe want to read 20 people for the
part you got 400 headshots you're
looking for any reason to get rid of
this you know these people anything
anything you can do to get someone off
the pilot programmers are not that
different you know if your film isn't
finished with a cuts not quite right yet
they're gonna that's a really good
reason for them to toss it aside again
unless you know somebody and they're
gonna give you that extra grain of salt
a little bit of attention there's no
point in doing that early so wait'll the
film's finished send it in then and look
at the schedule and say what's the next
if you if you're gonna apply to major
film festivals what's the next two major
film festivals that are coming up that I
could submit early to this Toronto South
by Southwest Sundance slam dance LA
South by that's really it if I start
with stop by and I may have a finalist
but those are the ones so if you finish
your film in December well it's too late
for Sundance and slam dance and maybe
even too late
for South by so maybe start start with
LA Film Festival and then Toronto and
those are your next two and then
anything after those two if those who
don't accept you you're not gonna get an
any major film festivals they're all
pretty much the same so or Tribeca and
mag yeah so go ahead and after that
point start looking at regional film
festivals that you've heard are good and
you know you want to know about film
festivals ask a filmmaker even
filmmakers that you don't know if
they're not you know famous major
filmmakers they'll be happy to write
back to you I actually had a blog
because I keep getting asked what my
favorite film fuzzles were just listing
here are my hair festivals here's why
they are my favorite festivals and there
were and there were regional festivals
they weren't like major ones they're
ones that indie filmmakers have a
reasonable shot of getting into if their
films decent I wrote that blog so I
could send it around and people would
say hey what's your favorite well here's
a list you know a Phoenix dead-center
Napa is a whole bunch of festivals that
that if you are outside the system and
you don't have major stars in your movie
and you made your film for twenty thirty
thousand dollars
if they like it they'll still play it
you're not running again you know we're
competing against Robert De Niro what's
the URL that block it's as just shut up
and shoot as my is my blog let's talk
about the more seasoned filmmaker what
are some of the politics and etiquette
that one should abide by when going and
asking for a fee being waived or a
lesser fee oh okay that's a good
question
you know I'm actually really a
about it what I do is I think a really
smart thing to do and this is this in
general is this be nice person and be
cooperative and be grateful when you get
him to a film festival and be friendly
with the staff film festival staff
aren't that different than any
filmmakers they're trying to put on a
show and make it and you know do you do
that's it I mean then you just same
thing you're doing so there's a lot of I
fight a lot of calming around with that
so you know you're you've been some
cameo and cast in their festival be cool
don't be a dick go down there and shake
their hand buy them a drink ask how you
can help and look at a help extend past
the end of the festival friend make
friends them on Facebook get their email
address and then when your new films
ready say hey I know I just want you
know my new films just just completed
and we're looking at the schedule we'd
love to be able to play your festival
again we're gonna be submitting so
usually they'll they'll they'll uh
they'll say yeah well don't pay a fee
whatever you do here's a way or fees
often they'll they'll ask sometimes so
I'll do that and almost always they'll
offer if they don't offer that I might
say well a possible we can get a maybe a
discount can then then they'll go oh
yeah you can get a waiver and or that or
some what's a discount Blaine Weaver I
know outright asks because he's CC me on
the emails to Austin can we get a fee
waiver I'm much more of a scaredy-cat
about it and actually and if I wasn't
friendly with the staff I we played for
example official rejection played the
waterfront Film Festival which I'd heard
great things about but it was a schedule
the exact same weekend as the
dead-center Film Festival which had
already committed to going to so I
didn't get to go to waterfront I felt
we played both vessels but no one was at
waterfront and I was a dead center
when favor came around I'm like whomp
some Bengal waterfront again because
again have heard good things
submitted to waterfront but I couldn't
just write them and go hey can I get a
waiver cuz I didn't show up the last
time I mean I told though I wasn't
showing up it wasn't a surprise but I go
so I paid the full fee and now we got in
and I did go this time and they were
like you're so cool for me like we
respected you so much more for paying
the fee because you didn't have to you
could have got a waiver I'm like didn't
like I had I didn't feel like I could
ask that of you but so let's suppose
you've been selected to be in seven
different festivals some of which you
may be able to attend some of which you
will not be able to go to what are some
of the things you should start doing
even if you can't go to them a filmmaker
should start doing to to grease those
wheels let them know knowing you may
want to come back in a couple years
things like that um okay well the
definitely what you want to do when you
get into a Film Festival is again just
be cool and be conscious of the schedule
you have to make a delivery to them so
you have to make so the first thing you
do is they'll usually they'll tell you
you're in first and then a day later
you'll get an email and they'll say can
you know please accept this invitation
they want to know you're in you accept
it then you'll get an email from them
with all their information like you know
thank you you've been a congratulations
you've been acceptable they'll tell you
like when it is what they provide in
terms of airfare hotel if anything about
have to provide something then talk
about you know when materials are do you
know what materials are what you score
your screening on so really you want to
think about right away you want to kind
of put together a schedule whereas we
have to have our master to them by this
date and they need this kind of master
didn't need a DCP do need blu-ray HD cam
I'm a V file whatever it is you want to
make sure you have that in your mind and
you also it's an automatic thing where
you want to create your bonus materials
you go okay well we need to have posters
and postcards and so forth and then you
want think about whether or not going to
go and if they're paying for airfare and
hotel it's way easier to decide but if
it's if it's if it's at the same time as
another
the Ville we had a case where we had
three at once like twice on the favor
circuit so at that point you say well
you know who's gonna go am i are are my
actors gonna go without me and you do
have if you have no like on favor we
have two solid lead actors the film is
the two of them pretty much for the
entire running time they're the two
leads the two character piece so and
they are both involved from even before
we started shooting during the writing
process so it's easy for me to say okay
Patrick day you're gonna go to this
festival Blaine Weaver you're gonna go
to this festival how many go to this
festival will divide and conquer and
every single festival gets some sort of
good representation of the movie they
get a you know someone who knows the
whole film the actor is less involved in
the behind the scenes you know obviously
the writer director editor is but they
were there and they're on camera and
that's way cool for an audience they see
the actor they just saw on screen do a
QA so figure out who's gonna go and if
you can get there get there but the
favorite was only only one festival this
run no one was able to get to which is
pretty cool I think with with official
it was about 40 percent
we couldn't get anybody there it just
happens you know you can't afford to get
at this time or it's this conflict with
something else but this we were very
fortunate because we had three people we
could divide up and send it four ways
but so that's the first thing you do is
start thinking about the deadlines you
know and it's work and also you know I
always say write to them ask them you
know you know knowledge everything great
thank you so keep it concise but
acknowledge it take it so much we'll
have all the materials to you there's
anything else you could do let me know
if you have any special things you can
ask for or offer rather so anything
special ease you can offer like if you
have we have you know this special
giveaway t-shirt package or let them
know about the right away and see if
they can use it if you're gonna go to
the festival also write to them and
volunteer well you know happy to do
panels or you know whatever you need me
to do so the you know you're
contributing to their show and part of
being grateful
and only the rare instance that you
can't make it like gets in a way
finances get in the way
right yeah finances again get in the way
what should you do maybe social media
wise or what can you do you know
virtually that could maybe make up for
some of that well whether you're there
or not you should do as much social
media as possible first of all find the
festivals Twitter handle Facebook
handles like them follow them usually
they'll follow you back or they'll find
you as well
yeah then if you have a website have a
shoot have a schedule a screening
schedule add a link a ticket link when
it becomes live - their screening date
time everything else everything you
would put on your postcard you can put
on your website including the link which
unlike a postcard is actually clickable
I have it updated all the time and yeah
I just always do social you should know
whether you're there or not I mean
doesn't really change it it's more
effective if you're there even so if you
know three people live in Delaware and
you're the Delaware Film Festival the
odds of them showing up to your
screening are hundreds of times higher
if you're actually going to be there to
have a drink with afterwards if you're
not there you know it's just it's
difficult for the festival festivals
position is you know anybody can go see
the new Tom Cruise movie any time it's
playing thirty five shows a week in it
on every other screen all throughout the
city but if you want to see such and
such you got to come this one time
there's one screen or maybe two times if
it's keep playing twice and a festival
but you know if this is are you not
gonna sing or anywhere else this is new
and exclusive and interesting and
different and any added value you can
add on to that event aspect really helps
the festival so you being there in
person it's a big deal I mean especially
in fin city in festivals that aren't
taking place in Los Angeles in New York
where there isn't as common for
filmmakers to just you know fall out of
the sky and talk about their film it's a
big deal I think it's a big deal for you
as a filmmaker to see your film with an
audience I don't watch the movie I watch
the audience watch the movie you learn a
lot and you got a lot of people talking
about your film and the questions they
ask and and they're more likely to
remember you when they leave because
remember festival is all about audience
building you know creating a brand for
your movie getting it out there in front
of audiences so that they remember you
and VOD or DVD happens
the line do you see a lot of filmmakers
doing those things that you've outlined
I mean they're all amazing tips and I
think that you know it's a this is
cliche but a recipe for success there we
go
okay so but do you see a lot of people
doing that I do see a lot of filmmakers
doing that you putting you meet the same
people on the circuit over and over and
over I think you know filmmakers in
general when you've worked for two or
three or four or five years on your
movie you're pretty I mean you're pretty
proud of it or at least you're pretty
proud of the accomplishment or you or
you want to talk about it it's like you
know you want to go and blather about
your stuff and and so getting in front
of an audience where they talk about
nothing but your movie is pretty
gratifying you know even with the
occasional oddball it goes off on a
tangent about something else in the
audience which this happened
periodically but even then I'm just
getting out there and glad-handing some
people don't like it though some people
do I know they're shy or their reclusive
or they don't want to talk about their
they they have they don't feel
comfortable doing it but it is part of
the job it's what I have to call the
politician of right the politician role
of the filmmaker were you afraid to go
out yeah you go out you're glad hand you
like kiss babies and do all those things
and you got to keep a straight face
during Q&A sometimes I know with
official rejection we screen in San
Diego and the very first screening we
had very first question of the Q&A I
opened it up this anybody come any
questions and this kind of Furnari win
it's too long like that and his wife is
what and I kind of display well sir not
really a question but thank you anybody
else I can easy you have to kind of
smile and move on from there without
getting mad or attacking your audience
or you know whatever else right heckling
back yeah heckling back you can't yeah
you gotta be cool you gotta respect
their ban I didn't like your movie okay
doesn't happen actually usually if they
don't like it they're gonna leave and
I've had a show on it with the official
rejection so we got Denver someone
keynote too as a filmmaker who I guess
program for Sundance was kind of
offended by the movie dad don't argue
with him just like okay you know hear
him out it's hard to do sometimes but
but being a politician is important for
audience building it's important for
network building again if you want to be
on the circuit the second third fourth
time and not spend thousands and
thousands of dollars getting your film
out there going out and glad
you know bringing the bring of staff
Pizza like the staff is working their
asses off in that office they haven't
seen daylight for weeks and when they do
it someone wanting something for them
some don't make her wanting to know why
this was pretty was two minutes later
something like that
so Denver stars we brought them like a
bunch of pies and they were like oh my
god I can't believe you brought us pies
and then I asked for a fee waiver
what flavor were they they were rhubarb
for they know pizzas so oh I know our
vow to Villa pizza in Denver best pizza
in the city better than Bo Joe's we
brought them stacks of those and they
were very happy going back to the being
the politician analogy which i think is
just brilliant so many filmmakers
sometimes seem like they get a little
nervous being in front of the crowd
whereas the actors love it and I know
there will be people in groups you know
if you ever watch like the Jerry
Springer Show whatever they love to test
that person in the hot seat and they
like to kind of see the reaction so
sometimes people stand up curious why
you did this BAM silence that you're on
so how would you advise the more shy
reclusive ahtur to handle that situation
because it inevitably will happen it
does you ask you basically you have to
man up in those situations and you have
to sort of you have to just be kind and
remember things from their point of view
I mean you start attacking the audience
you know it's not cool no one they are
even your your your allies the answer my
god man you know we had a thing at the
qat for favor the very first the very
first world premiere it was a really
good Q&A but we have one guy in the
audience they start talking about Mad
Men because in favor blame Weaver's
character it works for an ad agency and
I I had worked in advertising and you
know there was a creative pitch I mean
there's the nice board remember he gets
dressed up at me to a client's but for
the most part these scruffy little hold
ends with like you know deaths covered
in papers and it's a product and and
just these notes and cartoons and just
weird stuff everybody's like you know
guys our sleeves rolled up and they're
not bouncing a ball against the wall
it's a very messy kind of low-key
low-rent environment so in the film
we shot it that way I mean part of it
was because we didn't have we couldn't
afford to you big ass offices but but we
shot the way I know it you know which is
a scruffy little you know work pit and
the guy the guy is all this older
gentleman from the audience started
going well you know because it's not for
several minutes he goes you know seeing
this low-rent scuzzy adages in this film
makes me wonder why you chose to do that
because most of us are just seeing what
Eddie's looking at it's just about AMC's
Mad Men new season him which is debuting
and June 5th or something like that he
you know those rooms are pristine I'm
just seeing these scuzzy scumbags Skid
Row looking he went on and finally and
he kept saying maybe AMC's Mad Men and I
finally said you sure do you work for
AMC I said well I work in advertising
this is what I'm used to I know that I'm
I'm sorry the reality of your 1960's
soap opera
it doesn't quite add up to you know this
this is not a AMC's Mad Men
there's no Dondre pretty yeah that guys
note he say called Blaine Weaver no Don
Draper so we're just kind of like we're
kind of like well I know it's a good
show you know that's a great use kind of
like you kind of justify your choice and
the guys are you say well you know yeah
it's a great show and you kind of find
something in his opinion or that
person's opinion too can see I can see
why you would say that hmm or I can i
sir I see your point of view you know
step into their shoes for a moment and
sort of see it from there sir or at
least say you can and I think often if
someone does have an axe to grind which
again does not happen very often but if
someone does have an axe to grind
they're confused about something in the
film and they see something either
negative or or murky hearing them out
and not belittling them treating them
like they're stupid or just people with
respect regardless of what they're
saying I think they're gonna be come
away feeling better about it
I was heard and they're gonna still
leave your screening happy and satisfied
well that didn't really was okay but I
like the guy you know or maybe they'll
go yeah you know that was pretty good
you know yeah there's one thing that I
wish had been different with the
what I was expecting but you know they
come away feeling better one of the
worst Q&A
I felt so bad was for a film called
coffee kill boss which is the opening
night film in Austin last year and I
know I know a couple of the cast members
and the movies not confusing at all I
mean it's a comedy and it's not anything
what happens in the film and I don't
know why this happened but at the qat
someone in the audience said so who was
the killer and I was like super like it
was reveal it was like a major reveal
who the killer was you're the killer I
mean like it was super obvious and the
director goes it was so and so so and so
was the killer well wait when well who
was well I thought so I was the killer
someone who obviously wasn't the killer
no no it was it was so and so well did
so-and-so survive well we saw them dead
in that scene with the knife and so that
way like it was like seven or eight
questions deep of people like asking him
story points that were painfully obvious
and I saw him afterward and I said don't
worry don't worry
it's the film's not confusing at all
like I don't know why you had this run
of people who didn't follow the movie
but I can't imagine why anybody would be
confused you didn't make a confusing
film because for him it must have been
like oh my god what have I done like no
one can follow this movie you know well
sometimes there's on public contrarians
that like to kind of be the one that
stands up yes whether it's in a
classroom or a work they loved and I
think the way to defuse those people is
agree with everything they're saying
because that actually diffuses a little
bit their whole purpose I think you
shouldn't keep mind you are in front of
it or in front of an audience when this
is happening it's not like a one-to-one
I think about you afterwards you still
be respectful but when you're in front
of a lot of other people you do have to
mean it's it's Obama at a town hall
meeting you got to you got to take down
that one that one really conservative
tea party person says well I don't like
this and you gotta kind of well actually
I understand your point of view I
understand this but you have to kind of
diffuse it but what I find often happens
almost always happens is again your QA
is your barometer of how the audience is
reacted so if you lose most people for
your QA and there's no reason to like
it's not because your screen name is
running late or there's something else
happening that they have to get to
normally if you lose most of your
audience's because I didn't like the
song it was half your audience you
divided the audience means half liked it
Hatton liked it it's a cult them but
people that stay or want to stand
because they enjoyed the movie and they
want to talk to you and find out
something about it you didn't like a
film you don't want to know about it so
almost everybody in your audience that
stays is on your side with favor we had
a really good retention in fact thank
God we had like 90 95 percent people
would consistently would stick around
for the Q&A so we were doing pretty well
and that said most q and A's most of the
people work almost almost every q Nate
everybody's cool because again they all
like the movie but every once in a while
every five or six q and A's is that one
detractor stands up and universally
almost every time you have to do
anything because the other audience
members will jump on him what do you
mean you know like oh I thought it was
too long it was a perfect length what
was too long what would you cut out what
would you cut it like it was you know
like they there's always that way they
stand up and sort of defend you you know
it's sort of interesting and again so
makes it way easier to be like the cool
guy in the room right because they don't
have to preventing anybody here you're
angry you're angry mob of fans just you
know they don't have to make fun of this
guy but you still kind of want to
another everybody's been like you're
moving you know just just the way it is
you can't there's nothing wrong with
someone who doesn't like your film and
just not their cup of tea whatever it is
so you have to be prepared for that and
respectful of it and hear them out
sometimes you'll learn more from those
that didn't like you to know that did
well what do you consider the minimum
cost a filmmaker should spend on their
festival run and we'll do season verses
beginner what's the minimum cost I don't
know that there is a minimum cost I mean
it's possible to spend nothing I think
you want to think of it more in terms of
how how many festivals do you want to
play I think is more a more of idea I
think you want to play if you you really
want to play 10 to 15 festivals if you
can over the course of a year to 16
months so I think you as you get close
to finishing your movie I think you want
to look at okay we think we'll be done
by May so we can it's maybe kind of too
late to submit definitely too late to
submit to Tribeca or LA probably too
late to spend to Toronto so maybe we do
try an early submission to Sundance and
slim if it's a first time your first
time feel my chrysanthus because then
that's only takes first-time filmmakers
to their competition category okay we're
going to submit to those two after that
will submit to regional festivals you
know that we can submit to reasonably
far enough in advance that we're getting
early submission fees and we have a
better chance of getting in and then you
start looking at the schedule and and
again talk to a filmmaker find which
ones you want to hit but I think you
want to try to get into 10 to 15 which
means applying to 40 to 60 festivals but
applying early where it's like $35
whatever is more advantageous and do it
slowly don't do it all at once because
festivals well I mean first of all a lot
of puzzles aren't open yet but also as
you start to play once you start to play
you start getting invited their places
oh I heard about your film and we want
to make this festival or you know as a
programmer at Waterfront that's our film
like it and recommended it to several
other festivals so we don't been
submitted to four or five other
festivals for free because just because
she heard of it so you know I think do
it slowly roll out slowly and dip your
toe in the water a little bit because if
you've done 10 submissions and you
haven't gotten into anything and they're
not and and there's a ver and you've
gotten some smaller festivals and
there's some regional festivals in there
and no one's biting then you might want
to take a look at your movie it may not
be for festivals but this you know again
like do your research as festivals for
everything if your films you know if
it's reasonably well made and you know
regardless of what it is
you should be able to get some decent
festival play because most films aren't
recently well made that's really the
trick is they say oh you know it's ten
thousand features made a year but only
you know one thousand are watchable in
anyway only thousand have real actors or
you know it's a much smaller pool so
there's you know there's there's a place
for place for you it's funny I get shot
it's genre dependent - like I've learned
that comedies have an easier time
getting programmed and dramas and the
romantic comedies have an easier time
than that because festivals have to
program a certain amount of lighter
material - for older audiences I mean
alrights has come in and they want to
see you know things that are different
they don't want to see blockbusters they
want to harken back to time movies
didn't suck so bad you know the
Hollywood ones but they also are you
know relatively conservatives they
occasionally want to see a love story
rather than all the dark d'urgell stuff
that most filmmakers like myself tend to
pour out so very often not I'll see your
manic comedy and I've seen some good
ones I have but often I'll go to
festivals here romantic comedy I'll go
that wasn't so good because it's a
romantic comedy they had to program -
and they only found one that they like -
the other one it's kind of just in there
but yeah there's there's a place for
everything so that's really there's no
minimum and you can get waivers and you
can get recommendations there's no
reason you can't spend zero but you want
to make sure your throw is big enough
that you take advantage of the circuit
that you're able to play a good
smattering around the country because
when you do go to VOD DVD whether you do
it through gravitas Pictures film buffer
by yourself you want your film to have
access to an audience favor will have
played 12 film festivals on its film
festival run and we have one more coming
up and we have I think as an average of
30,000 attendees per festival that's the
average
so that's 360,000 people that have been
exposed to our advertising material
thanks to these non sundance festivals
you know these regional festivals there
all over the country
so that's pretty good throw and when we
come out on VOD in April 1st April 1st
we come on VOD I'm gonna be writing
every one of this vessel saying hey you
know can you go on Twitter and tweet
about us can you know give a newsletter
can you put us in your newsletter can
you send an email I'll be email blast
out to your email people can your
mailing list can you put us in the news
items in your webpage and festivals even
though the festival only runs part of
the year they're operating year-round
they want to stay relevant your rap so
some on their own theatres some do
screenings and fundraisers throughout
the year some of mini offshoot versions
of themselves like we have the horror
one in October we have but they want to
stay relevant and in and your success is
their success you know you're forever an
alumni of that festival so hey we're the
dead-center Film Festival that's still
we played is doing well well that looks
reflects well on them and people that
they're sending that blast to saying
they're on VOD have been exposed to the
programs and you know festival genius
all the things that happen when we did
play there last summer so even if they
didn't see the film there's some brand
awareness that's important so moving
forward I think you definitely want to
have if you're going to do festivals a
big enough chunk and that's really what
you want to hit regardless of how much
money you spend this is my hands I don't
know why I'm doing it
what should the George Hill filmmaker
who's brand new who wants to know about
a particular Film Festival do should
they find out from some of the alumni
are find those filmmakers websites and
then just shoot them a quick email and
what should that email say newbie
filmmakers can write to the filmmakers
that have been in other festivals their
best bet is to go to they'll festivals
website look at the kinds of films that
have played at that festival see if
they're in the same species as their own
movie if their all-star vehicles that
came out of Sundance the product can
play your little film will throw a local
Alabama films you're not a local how
about a film they're probably not gonna
play your film if they play it mostly
foreign films they play social
consciousness movies and your film is a
maurer movie you know make sure you fit
the program then yeah if you want to
know about it I've done this is you
write to filmmakers that have been at
that felt this is actually good idea for
anything
talking to a distributor talking to a
film rep look on their website and see
who's played their festival who they
represented her who've been distributed
by the distributor whoever it is and
write to those filmmakers because nine
times out of ten they'll write back to
you and to say hey you know you know my
name is you know my name is Paula
Osbourne I made this phone call favor
we're considering submitting to the
indie Memphis Film Festival we see we
saw you play there last year if you
wouldn't mind letting us know whether
it's worth our time it looks like a good
festival but sometimes you can tell from
website what were your impressions was a
good bad don't do it through the
festival or through the don't ask them
who can I talk to go to our website and
write them independently because
obviously you want to get a real answer
well at times out of 10 and then unless
you're writing to this the the studio
film that was there you know the opening
night studio film if you're writing to a
film that's around the same again in the
same species as your movie
they'll probably write back to you and
they'll be honest because filmmakers
tend to like to help out the filmmakers
you know I find much more of a
Brotherhood and then then maybe I think
maybe I think sometimes distributors
wish it was they wish we would find it
out but I think it's I mean I like out
with the filmmakers